salvare un castello pensando credendo
che potesse bastare la sola forza delle
idee da questo costruire un gruppo
la fondazione con la fondazione
viaggiare su un doppio binario parallelo
da una parte il restauro conservativo e
filologico dall'altro il suo riutilizzo
come un sistema culturale locale
ma dove siamo
siamo a padernello una piccola frazione
di 76 abitanti nel comune di borgo san
giacomo in provincia di brescia
siamo nella bassa più bassa della bassa
bresciana una chiesa 5 6 grandi cassine
un castello il castello in castello
medioevale nasce come torre di
avvistamento verso la fine del 1300 nel
1400 la famiglia martinengo siamo nel
periodo alle lotte fra milano e venezia
il fiume oglio fa da confine questa
famiglia mattina ngo costruisce questi
palazzi verso il 1485 1490 viene un po
concluso come casa fortezza verso la
fine del cinquecento viene sopra alzato
e prende le attuali forme
verso la metà del settecento viene
trasformata in una residenza signorile
1834 muore questo girolamo silvio
martinengo non ha discendenti e la passa
alla famiglia salvadego perché vi
racconto questo perché la famiglia
salvadego poi lo abiterà fino al 1965
dal 1965 fino al 2005 questo castello
resterà disabitato allegoria del tempo
degli uomini delle persone
i piccioni abbiamo fatto dei danni
inenarrabili abbiamo fatto delle cose
impensabili
ecco nel 2002 c'è l'ultimo crollo
sembrava l'ultimo messaggio che il
castello stava mandando così salvata e
un misurate io crollo questo bene
storico lo perdiamo completamente ci
aveva provato un'associazione per un po
di tempo a mettere in campo alcune
iniziative ma sono sempre quelle cose
dove crediamo che la bellezza sia sempre
la cosa che ci muove di più la bellezza
se non diventa un valore patrimoniale
non è sufficiente
ecco che allora il comune di borgo san
giacomo decide di fare l'acquisto quando
sta per acquistarlo
alla fine entra nelle solite
problematica il comune non ce la fa ci
sono i patti di stabilità ecco che
allora inventiamo la prima operazione
l'acquisto facciamo pubblico privato 51
per cento del comune il bene indiviso e
del comune il 49 per cento di privati il
pubblico e privato messi ma sembrava il
diavolo e l'acquasanta invece questa
cosa funziona
poi nello stesso anno dopo fatto
l'acquisto il 31 maggio 2005 il 15
sempre ad ogni cinque costituiamo la
fondazione una fondazione di
partecipazione e anche questo è una
forma innovativa che suggerisco
qualsiasi persona ente debba aiutare la
rinascita è un bene culturale
fate una fondazione di partecipazione è
un ente pubblico di diritto privato che
macheda la velocità che ti permette di
fare le cose di fare le cose veloci ma
prima di fare le cose veloci
pensiamo prima dell'azione il pensiero
noi abbiamo speso uno studio di
fattibilità
ci abbiamo pensato ci abbiamo riflettuto
e poi l'abbiamo presentato in
sovrintendenza togliamo un'altra un
altro mito la sovrintendenza non ti
aiuta mai siamo dati dalla
sovrintendenza abbiamo presentato il
progetto dopo 15 giorni avevamo il
parere del sovrintendente che
autorizzava a partire a fare questo
restauro
dovete che se le cose vengono fatte con
capacità e anche con competenza le cose
funzionano di un pensiero progettuale
l'altra cosa l'abbiamo fatta anche con
la costituzione della fondazione avremmo
potuto mettere delle persone che si
erano fatte avanti abbiamo selezionato
chi poteva entrare a fare i soci
fondatori 5 banca di credito cooperativo
dico che sono deputate a salvaguardare
il territorio e quindi le abbiamo unite
la cogema con società di servizi del
nostro territorio che rappresento 70
comuni
il comune di borgo san giacomo
naturalmente e poi la società di privati
e poi altri privati 11 soci fondatori e
gli abbiamo fatto versare una piccola
quota di partenza da lì siamo partiti
per cominciare a fare le opere di
restauro
perché quando siamo arrivati noi avevamo
di fronte un grande problema
il castello accaduto è crollato
l'abbiamo trasformato una grande
opportunità
la visione che quando abbiamo trovato
noi ci fermiamo
è una cosa che deve essere superata il
problema è una grande opportunità ecco
che questo noi l'abbiamo fatto
mentre cominciavamo abbia fatto la
fondazione che dicevano al 2005 a fine
anno all'inizio 2006 già cominciavamo
restaurare i tetti quindi man mano
facevamo le iniziative andavano avanti e
quindi facevamo anche alle
manifestazioni
quindi da una parte ristrutturavano
dall'altra watt e riutilizzarlo quindi
abbiamo siamo partiti subito nel 2006 il
restauro della parte crollata nel 2007
abbiamo restaurato la parte che l'ha
dedicata alle librerie e biblioteche
abbiamo cominciato a fare teatro
presentare i libri nel 2008 e 2009
abbiamo risistemato tutta la parte del
cortile con un grande bando della
fondazione cariplo verso la creazione di
sistemi culturali e li abbiamo fatto un
po il salto di qualità ci siamo posto
ghana ti siamo andati un po a livello
regionale e abbiamo cominciato a fare le
iniziative perché dicevamo abbiamo
restaurato il cortile le facciate lo
scalone ma abbiamo fatto partire ha
subito cinque iniziative tra le quali
questa slow food
quando io ho cominciato i miei amici
dicevano ma si facciamo il mercato
vedremo due caciotta l scherzavano a
caso il mercato slow food
attualmente lombardia ce ne sono due uno
a milano e uno a padernello 1 a qualche
milioni di persone noi abbiamo 76
abitanti
il mercato ci porta 3 mila persone ogni
domenica che facciamo il mercato
facciamo la terza domenica del mese
quindi vuol dire che questo ci porta
30.000 persone
sapete quante iniziative facciamo in un
anno 200 220 giorni i manifesti
azione in un anno facciamo 220 giorni di
manifestazioni all'anno e facciamo da
zero
sessantamila visitatori quindi vuol dire
che abbiamo attivato questo processo ma
perché l'abbiamo fatto questa cosa qui
perché non abbiamo ascoltato quelli che
dicono questi beni devono essere salvati
dallo stato dalla regione dal comune
questi beni di salviamo noi perché
questi beni noi amiamo perché noi
crediamo fortemente che se abbiamo la
forza la capacità la competenza la
passione questa parola discriminate che
diventa questa grande virtù la
perseveranza che sarebbe una perso la
passione che dura nel medio lungo
periodo sono in grado di fare piani
strategici quinquennali capire quando
sono solo le soluzioni creare quello che
dicevamo un progetto che qui vedete
identificato il 9 progetti siamo stati
in grado di mettere in campo nove
progetti il teatro il cinema e lo
gastronomia le mostre il progetto
culturale e attraverso tutti questi
progetti a cui ognuno ha un responsabile
e ognuno è uno sponsor nove progetti 9
responsabili 9 sponsor
ecco dove viaggiamo la visione chiara la
missione chiarissima trasparente per cui
quando andiamo a fare una ricerca fondi
che credetemi una ricerca fondi pazzesca
perché noi siamo perdere niente
facciamo il piano va se non va piano a b
abbiamo il b poi abbiamo ci di scorta
perché naturalmente
capite bene che in un luogo come questo
perché questa è una terra dura di fatica
di sudore non è che ti regalano niente
quindi e poi a padernello ci deve
arrivare per forza in stradine piccole
strette sono il vecchio li misero mano
che abbiamo mantenuto quindi non era
facile quindi arrivare lì ecco questo ci
ha permesso di arrivare a quello che
dicevo ieri sera anticipavo questo
nostro percorso verso la felicità una
scorciatoia verso la felicità perché qui
noi abbiamo creato competenza capacità
economia territoriale e l'abbiamo fatto
con la sostenibilità
qui vedete i nostri dati dopo dieci anni
è sondato i piccoli non sono dati da
miliardi di euro però lo in dieci anni
dieci anni di gestione positiva è da
sfatare io ho visto qualcuno che diceva
no bisogna presentare i bilanci con dei
margini negativi perché se vediamo che è
in perdita si sovvenziona fesserie
gigantesca se tu sei già in perdita
soldi non te ne daranno mai allora noi
noi invece abbiamo sempre fatto i
margini positivi abbiamo raccolto in
dieci anni due milioni e mezzo di euro
più 500mila euro che ci ha dato la
carica 3 milioni di euro se all'inizio
di questa nostra avventura avessimo
detto tra di noi ragazzi che bisogna
accogliere tre milioni di euro 6
miliardi di vecchie lire
non saremo mai partiti dovrebbe mai
partito in su ecco perché abbiamo
bisogno dei piani strategici pluriennali
fare le cose piano dopo piano passo dopo
passo perché i risultati arrivano noi
siamo convintissimi che abbiamo davanti
progetti ancora per lungo periodo e la
sostenibilità una parola chiara e quindi
se non abbiamo la sostenibilità questi
baby e clicca dono nuovamente quindi
dobbiamo immaginarci di trovare il
nostro bilancio per il 75 per cento è
dato da iniziative che noi mettiamo in
campo da contributi che andiamo a
ricercare da scorso che troviamo prima
di fare le manifestazioni
il tempo è breve io stavo devo stare nei
miei tempi però abbia falsi facciamo
mostre ci propongono un mostro da tutte
le parti ne facciamo mai mai neanche uno
di quelli che ci propongono perché
costano una cifra pazzesca le mostra ce
lo costruiamo noi e nostra mostra fanno
dei 6 mila e 10 mila visitatori e cosa
fanno le nostre mostre propongono
assolutamente di andare a promuovere il
territorio
adesso partiamo velocemente perché il
tempo mi stringe per presentare quali
sono i nostri tre progetti che abbiamo
in corso adesso economia circolare
assegnatari di un bando sull'economia
circolare di tre di 136mila euro
l'economia lineare produco consumi
faccio rifiuti ormai al termine
le risorse non sono infinite dobbiamo
pensare un nuovo progetto è quello che
noi stiamo pensando è che diventiamo per
l'ennesima volta
esempio sul territorio dove produciamo
consumiamo riutilizziamo ecco su questo
stiamo inventando alcune iniziative ci
stiamo pensando
l'altra operazione che abbiamo in corso
qui tra l'altro mette nella fotografia
questo bellissimo ponte di giuliano
mauri che collega una roggia perché
oltre a questo abbiamo anche unito
l'arte di arte questi artisti di arte
naturale
questo è sulla resilienza è un bando che
esce ha quindi cominciato incrociare le
dita perché bando esce martedì dalla
fondazione cariplo pd mercoledì sappiamo
i risultati se va questo secondo noi
cominciamo a pensare che questo shock
del territorio che è un'agricoltura
massiva ha fatta da l'utilizzo di
granoturco e che consuma una grande
quantità di acqua in modo
anticrittogamici diserbanti e ci rovina
assolutamente il paesaggio noi vogliamo
invertire agricoltura di prossimità
farro grano monococco creiamo la filiera
del pane chi mette il grano turchi mette
il grano deve sapere che chi acquista le
farine e già glielo compra che poi
formare gli compra le farine che i
gruppi di acquisto solidali comprano il
pane piccola filiera ma la facciamo
partire albergo diffuso
l'albergo diffuso un altro progetto che
noi abbiamo in corso perché il museo non
è il paesino il museo non è il castello
è il paesino cielo aperto che è il mondo
contadino di una volta e.coli noi
vogliamo portare le persone che spiano
di avere la recettività perché nel
frattempo tra parentesi nel paesino e 76
abitanti sui partiti tra i ristoranti
che fanno 80 90 mila persone all'anno
quindi abbiamo creato questo indotto già
erano partiti all'inizio anche loro ecco
quindi questi sono i tre progetti
poi il futuro perché il futuro non basta
solo immaginarlo
il futuro bisogna anche a scriverlo e
quindi noi lo scriviamo attraverso
pensare di fare impresa sociale il
braccio della fondazione che un braccio
costituito esclusivamente tranne un
dipendente dal volontariato 60 persone
che lavorano con noi deve essere
assolutamente rafforzato
bisogna modificare e integrare la
governance della fondazione creando
l'impresa sociale e dando corpo alla
nostra nuova ossessione
dare lavoro e giovani quindi questi
giovani devono entrare andava a
ricoprire i posti di responsabilità dove
andremo creare queste scuole di buona
gestione
la buona gestione l'abbiamo dimostrata
in dieci anni quindi credo che non
abbiamo bisogno di imparare niente su
quel lato quindi abbiamo dimostrato
faremo la scuola di buona gestione alla
scuola di alta formazione alla scuola
dai camerieri ci sono i ristoranti
quindi attivare lavoro per i giovani
dall'altra parte devono diventare il
braccio operativo della fondazione
nostro volontariato che ha una certa età
come la mia quindi comincerà il
affaticato dal tempo dovrà essere
sostituito da questi giovani che facendo
i responsabili di queste iniziative
dalla cooperativa sociale dell'intera
sociale diventeranno anche la forza
nuova della fondazione quindi questo
abbiamo in campo e poi per terminare
ecco credo di essere nei tempi per
terminare c'è questa idea
sull'artigianato dalle scuole bottega
delle botteghe rinascimento siamo andati
in regione per denis ma guarda che
questo è il progetto che ti dico sì ma
non è previsto e chiaro che non previsto
su tutto opposto a chiederti di
modificarlo quindi questo e quindi
chi state guardate che se sforo è colpa
vostra perché aveva applaudito quindi
perché stavamo dicendo che la perché
l'artigianato perché il lavoro non si
cerca il lavoro si crea quindi se noi
creiamo lavoro di piccoli piccoli numeri
li facciamo e andiamo avanti e termino
dicendo questo proverbio africano che
dice che tante persone in tanti piccoli
posti che fanno tante piccole cose sono
in grado di cambiare il mondo
noi ci proviamo con il nostro metodo
ascoltando il nostro cuore perché esso
conosce tutte le cose
grazie
io sono andato a vedere
brava
sarà spento
lo prendiamo come consulente perché noi
qui nel nostro territorio abbiamo molte
cose che potrebbe rimettere in piedi
però ci vuole il merito di aver sfidato
un gruppo noi ci proviamo